a local teenager headed home after being
hospitalized for months
emma berkey has been battling rare brain
blood clots after receiving
the johnson and johnson vaccine
christian cossa is joining us live in
studio with an update
on her road to recovery brian it's been
a long road but the family says emma
is coming home which is great news her
mom posting pictures
on social media saying she's getting a
little better each day check out
the pictures here emma's family shared
on social media they show the 18 year
old as she gets ready to leave a loma
linda hospital
in southern california after suffering a
stroke she underwent three brain
surgeries
emma was one of six women in the nation
who suffered rare
but severe blood clocks after back in
april after getting the single dose
johnson and johnson vaccine
the family pastor and spokesperson tells
us that her communication
and her personality have returned but
her left side of her body is not fully
responding
that includes her left leg which is
preventing her from walking
emma's going to do physical therapy
every day up here in the las vegas
valley just like she was doing there so
a typical day for her will be get up in
the morning go to rehab from nine
till two in the afternoon and her rehab
basically will be her full-time job
this week the fda warned the johnson
johnson vaccine can lead to an increased
risk of a rare neurological condition
a rare syndrome that one in every
million develop every year in the us
now a gofundme page has generated over
60 thousand dollars for emma
and that amount keeps growing the family
says that support and all the prayers
are giving them hope if you'd like to
donate to her recovery we have a link on
our website eightnewsnow.com
christian gossip is 8 news now